if you're lying then it would be easier
on my mind I won't have to show you any
mercy I can defeat you without
hesitation hello and welcome to Hunter
hunter 101 the series that breaks down
everyone and everything in the Hunter
hunter world and today is a most
momentous occasion because we are going
to be kicking off our mighty adventure
through the series without ever lovable
protagonists gone freaks gone freaks is
an incredibly enthusiastic yet
simple-minded young boy hailing from the
realm of whale island who was inspired
to become a hunter in order to find his
father Jing freaks he is best
characterized by his unwavering
determination always striving to become
stronger and generally positive attitude
towards life however God certainly isn't
without a dark in nature particularly
when his emotions become ignited in the
results of such a situation occurring
can vary greatly generating everything
from comical anger to deathly serious
and at times terrifying intentions
however before we get to that let's cut
back to his origins on whale island Jing
broke onto the island when he was a
toddler planning to leave the child in
his grandmother's care but ultimately it
would be jinkx cousin Mito who took
custody of gone and raised him now due
to me toes how shall we say heavy
distaste words Jing gon was told that
his parents had died in an accident
however eventually the truth of Jing
would be revealed when gone encountered
kite a student of jinx who greatly
admired his teacher and it would be this
admiration that sparked gongs ambition
and he resolved to become a hunter and
one day find his father then as a
parting gift kite even provided gone
with jinx hunters license and so young
gone proceeded to apply for the 287
hunter exam which involved him leaving
whale island and becoming entangled in a
series of physical and mental tests of
extraordinarily and even fatal
difficulty but he had gone would go in
to meet three very important individuals
that would go on to greatly inform his
life being the Oreo Korra pika and most
importantly kilowatt given that they
were exactly the same age kilowatt and
gone almost immediately became best
friends and the two would go on to form
one of if not the strongest bond in the
series it wasn't all good times were
gone though as this exam would be the
stage upon which he would meet with his
eternal antagonist the magician Hisoka
and after being thoroughly humiliated
during one of the stages of the exam
gone resolved to become strong enough to
one day defeat the magician as for the
rest of the exam though gone made it
through to the final phase where he was
bit against an infinitely stronger
opponent in the form of Hanzo however
due to the rules of the final stage
forbidding the killing of an opponent
and Gaunt's phenomenal determination in
the way of not giving up Hanzo
forfeiting the match leading a greatly
injured going to receive his very own
hunters license however unbeknownst to
gan this was not in fact the end of the
hunter example merely the beginning of a
new phase in which the examinees are
taught the art of nen and this would
occur when gone and kill what
encountered winged during the stint at
the heavens arena gone along with kill
oh I proved to be a natural study and
were able to master the four major
principles being tens at superin and hot
suit by the out of water divination GaN
also learnt that he was an enhancer
meaning that he specializes in using men
to increase the natural abilities of his
own body or selected objects although
with this classification it should also
be noted that gone has a somewhat
natural access to both the emitter and
transmutation and classes albeit at a
lesser rate of mastery so over the
course of his career gone has used men
primarily for offensive benefits having
developed a set of attacks that
correlate with Junkin or scissors paper
rock in English or rock-paper-scissors
in American English
each of these utilize one have gone
three primary nine classes and result in
fairly devastating damage if they manage
to connect with an opponent but after
learning the basics of Nan gone managed
to defeat an opponent on the 200th war
of the heavens arena which was a
condition that needed to be met in order
for the magician who soccer to accept
God's challenge to a fight and so the
two of them fought in the arena with
gone immediately displaying his
phenomenal growth in terms of strength
speed and general ingenuity since their
last encounter during the hunter exam
however despite this growth his Walker
still managed to win the match with
relative ease although afterwards he
went on to declare that their next match
would be a fight to the death
acknowledging his weakness gone once
again resolved to become stronger and
continue down his path of perpetually
striving for power and this is a
particular characteristic that separates
him from his contemporary Shonen
counterparts because god's desire for
power is often characterized through
anger and as such he often becomes
blinded by a rationality leading to some
extraordinarily reckless tendencies that
leave him in potentially fatal
situations in fact despite being
generally portrayed as a joyous young
boy Kahn's morality actually lands quite
firmly in the gray area as he seemingly
has no interest in things that are good
or bad but instead only what piques his
curiosity and gone has even be shown is
willing to let others die in order to
achieve his own personal goals
speaking of said goals following the
heavens arena Rock go on returned to
whale island with kilowatt and received
a clue from his father Jing in the form
of a memory card for a joy Station game
called greed island very eventually gone
and kilowatt were able to access this
game in which players bodies were
seemingly transported inside of the game
however in actuality they were
transported to a small isolated island
in the real world on this island gone
and kill
would encounter Biscay and under her
tutelage gone proceeded to master some
more advanced known techniques such as
Co Andrew eventually gone and killer
what were able to beat greed island by
collecting all 100 restricted cards only
to learn the game was created by Jing
all along it's another very prominent
figures and using one of the games cards
known as accompany gon and killua
transported themselves to a person on
their contact list whose name was an
anagram of Jing although instead of
finding God's father they ended up being
taken to his former student kite thus
beginning the Chimera ant arc during
this time gone and Killa accompanying
kite as he investigated the chimera ants
who eventually evolved power beyond
comprehension with one of the managing
to go so far as to kill kite gone
strongly believing that kite was still
alive vowed to rescue him eventually
culminating in grown and kilowatt taking
part in the palace invasion the
desperate attempt to kill the king of
the chimera ants maro em as well as his
three royal guards one of which never
pitot had been responsible for killing
cut completely blinded by his ambition
gone sought out in fop toe and this
showed us a particularly dark side of
our protagonist who was consumed by
anger and later despair when it became
apparent that NetHope toe would be
unable to revive cut and in this moment
of realization gone unleashed everything
anger sorrow despair and all of the nen
power that he would ever have access to
resulting in a transformation into an
older version of himself with strength
comparable to that of the Chimera and
king marijuana and thus becoming one of
the most terrifying ly powerful
characters in the entire series using
this power gone proceeded to brutally
kill Nephi Peter
at one stage using his own severed arm
to impale PTO's headless body afterwards
gone returned to his former self albeit
in a comatose state and having destroyed
himself beyond repair the only thing
that awaited him was death
although luckily kilowatt managed to get
gone to help in time and then even went
on to invoke the power of his younger
sibling Aloka who was possessed by a
being from the dark continent and had
the power to heal gone after his
recovery gone was taken to the hunter
chairman election where he finally met
his father Jing but this moment would be
cut short as gone and left to visit kite
who had been reborn not only as a
chimera ant
but his marijuana twin sibling by the
time gone returned Jing had left him a
message to meet him at top the world
tree and after climbing almost two
kilometres to the talk on would finally
be properly reunited with Jing who
enlighted gone to the existence of the
outside world namely the Dark Continent
after this conversation gone realized
that he could no longer use his aura
although Jing did suggest that it had
the potential to be reawakened or
alternatively that God could take this
chance to live and
life and with the goal of finding his
father completed gone then returned to
whale island and recommence life as a
regular teenager schoolwork and or some
more fun facts about gone in the manga
and the 2011 anime series one typically
speaks in an informal manner about Jing
tending to call his father old man and
later on even by his first name whereas
in the 1999 anime adaptation they went
for a more formal approach with gon
referring to Jing as his father
despite being arguably the primary
protagonist of the series gone has
ranked 3rd in all three character
popularity polls conducted by weekly
shonen jump behind the admittedly fan
based power houses that are kilwa and
keroppi counts by being a great thinker
in the art of combat Khan's brain
capacity does not extend to the realm of
mathematics often miss reading and miss
calculating basics arms too great a
comical effect gongs birthday is on May
5th also known as Children's Day in
Japan
meaning that he shares a birthday with
the main protagonist of one piece Monkey
T Luffy and finally a truly useless fact
in Malay gone freaks is called Gong si
pelic literally meaning the weird gone
but that pretty much does it for gone if
you enjoyed this video and the content
this channel produced in general then
please do consider donating to the new
world revue patreon because the support
of all of you amazing people is what
continues to make this channel possible
and if patreon isn't quite your style
then please do leave this video a like
share or subscribe because it also helps
support this channel an incredible
amount and if you'd like to join the fun
at any time then please do head over to
my discord server where a wide array of
shenanigan retakes place on a daily
basis and finally please do comment with
who what or where you'd like to see
featured in the next Hunter hunter 101
[Music]
[Music]
that's the guy on the left write down
the rights like mm-hmm
it's like a question mark that's that's
that's what a question mark would sound
like if you did it
mm-hmm